Susy starts off this hour in Hawaii
hi Susy welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hi how's it going better than I deserve
what's up good that's good my husband
and I both have received an inheritance
this year he is Australian so he was
Australian inheritance so we put it in a
bank in Australia it's 115,000 and we've
kept that there because it's exchange
rate is so low so we elect in Australia
and I've just received about 350,000 and
so we are self-employed
so you don't have any retirement so just
want to know best thing to do with our
money you read that we do we have a
house mortgage two hundred thousand in
business credit card bills we have about
twenty thousand and then IRS repayment
plan thirteen thousand and auto loan at
about four thousand okay if you raise
your right hand and promise to never
borrow money again and if you get on a
budget to prove it that you're never
going to borrow money again and if you
start handling money together to where
you never repeat the mistakes they've
gotten you into the message you just
described then I would write a check and
pay off all these debts and I'd be a
hundred percent free and then I would
use the household cash flow that used to
use used to be used for payments to
build wealth with and you'll have the
three hundred thousand back in no time
but if you pay off everything and you
continue your sloppy disorganized ways
of buying crap you can't afford you're
gonna go back into debt and this money's
going to have vaporized on you right so
that's the discussion you've got to have
at your house is
are we going to honor the memory of the
person who left us this money by
changing our financial habits to look
more like theirs because that's how they
got that money they didn't have IRS they
don't have RS liens and car payments
right okay and so if you're willing to
do that then the the proper advice would
be to pay off everything it might be a
good idea to say all right I'm gonna pay
off the IRS today that's kind of a
no-brainer right and I'm gonna pay off
my car payment today and what was the
other day other than the house um so my
credit card yeah I'm gonna cut up the
credit cards and never use them again
I'm gonna pay off all the debts except
my home and then I'm gonna get on a
written budget and I'm gonna be proved
to myself that I'm disciplined and once
you've proven that to yourself and
you've lived on less than you make and
you start building up some savings
because of that then that would get set
you free to write the check out of the
inheritance money and pay off the house
I'd be a little worried with no track
record of being disciplined that you
suddenly would grow discipline right if
I were you I'd be limey knime a little
worried about me and chocolate chip
cookies right now so you know I may be
72% gravy by this time Thursday so I
mean you know I'm a little worried about
all of us but so the point is don't you
know don't fool yourself I probably
would go through Financial Peace
University I pay off all the little
debts and then let's get on it let's
have a new life because of this that
sets us free to build wealth and you
know clear that going clear that
mortgage after you've been disciplined
for six months you've been in control
for six months and you've vowed that
we're never borrowing money ever again
because you shouldn't need to if you got
no payments you ought to be able to save
money like a WoW person right so what is
the history of the exchange rate with
Australia I don't know the history as it
always been about is it always been
about where it is or is it just recently
gotten on it's been about the same for a
couple years maybe one or two years okay
so what makes you think it's gonna
change in the next two or three years
yeah that's what we're thinking so you
do think it's gonna change in the next
room no no you don't well if it's not
gonna change there's no point in leaving
it there you might as well take the hit
and move it on over whatever the
exchange rate issue is and get your
investments all stateside and start you
know if you live in the United States
start doing you know good mutual funds
and that kind of stuff there's no rush
but I mean if you if there's a I do not
know any history at all on the
Australian exchange rate I know nothing
about it so if I were you though I'd be
studying it because the only reason to
leave it in an Australian bank is
because you think that in a few years
it's gonna get better but if you if you
have no reason based on history and
track record I think it's gonna get
better then you're leaving it there for
no reason might as well just say this is
what the exchange rate is it's not you
know it's just not good that's the way
it is